you
[Music]
a brief intro here for myself My name is
Matthew Seale I work at Netflix on the
Big Data Platform team in particular I
work on orchestration systems are
helping schedule and manage execution of
work for on behalf of other engineers so
I do a lot of integrations with data
engineers and data analysts as well as
like system devs aren't is used to that
realm that need to be able to get their
data or some analytics about their
service or app in a patterns they
haven't used yet that data engineering
is more familiar with so it becomes a
kind of a bridge point for a lot of
different user groups that all need the
same needs so what's this kind of look
like and what does a data platform team
do I think in this crowd it'll be a
little more well known but just as a
kind of walk through and rehash of how
this works for us you have many
different data inputs these can be
events from different you know click
actions or user input data or system
metrics or other sources of data and
they all need to be kind of ETL you know
we need to extract that data and
transform it into something useful and
this is where the data platform services
come in which is the types of systems I
helped build basically you want to feed
this raw data into some some useful
State and then you're going to put it
through some transfer you can put in
other systems you're gonna get it to
certain users and then you can do some
sort of aggregations or machine learning
or reporting on it and the final outcome
on the the far right is that you want to
basically have some business value
actions as a result of the data being
processed so the big platform services
team is really about building the tools
so that people trying to get the data
from the left to the right can do their
job easier and that's part of what I'm
talking about here is kind of using a
technology that we're gonna dig into in
a minute that's helped this process some
and making a little smoother for users
especially users that aren't as familiar
with traditional tools alright so you
know since we're a Netflix talk we have
to do some memes or some show references
so one thing you know what what's Data
Platform do you at the end of the day we
open doors just not this one
so I'm gonna be talking a little bit
about open source projects in Jupiter
and interact interact is a group of
libraries it's got a github and nice on
my documentation that is like a
ecosystem of tools around the Jupiter
ecosystem which is a broader group of
tools for doing different programming
models and data munging and the kind of
ownership model here is these are open
source projects all the link I'm talking
about our open source but then Netflix
is a large contributor into these
projects and we try to be as supportive
of the open source as we can all right
so the thing wearing actually jump into
first is what are jupiter notebooks the
the tool we're going to talk about later
is called paper mill but if you don't
know what jupiter notebooks are it'll be
a little hard to talk about so a
notebook is effectively a an interface
that has a ripple to ripple that's
executing code on your behalf so it's
sort of like the way if you have an
interface that has broken down pieces of
code you can execute individually and
sort of iterate through independently
the interesting thing with notebooks is
that it's a little more human-friendly
into the sense that has a little more
web integration and a little more
integration with visuals built out of
the box it also has the ability to
replace particular code snippets over
and over again while the state of your
of your execution is being held in the
background so much like a ripple where
you can have an open console and you
maybe make some programming calls and
then you make additional programming
calls and keep iterating until you get
some solution you like it's a sort of a
way of tracking that and I'm in a more
like collected and human friendly manner
like the what what the breakdown this
actually gives you in completeness is
really around the code that you want to
have executed as well as markdown and
documentation and the ability to log the
outcome so one of the really nice things
is is as your code executes you can
actually see all the outputs like the
STD out there CD air you can output
displays even objects that you have that
you just have allocated you can render
those automatically with like standard
conversions to text outputs or visual
outputs it has a really nice things like
what you are executing and what the
outcomes were all bundled together one
place where this really shines is for
iterative development so if you don't
quite know what your code needs to look
like yet or you don't
your data shape looks like it's a really
handy tool for being able to kind of
explore without having to redo all the
computation over and over again from
scratch it's also really handy to share
results you can or to integrate with
various API calls so here you can kind
of play out how you did something like
integrates tool or experiment something
or produce up something you can share it
by just giving this notebook file or the
adult book link to someone else and they
can reproduce exactly what you ran and
that's really important for later what
we're gonna talk about so break down
like what are these pieces over here on
the right is the interactive version of
the UI there's 700 of you eyes there's
like a status and koryu standard like
file operators at the top and then
you'll have this thing called a code
cell so that block of code right there
is called a cell and that's what your
input to the system is and then your
outputs are displayed in between the
cells so you'll see we had three cells
here one was a markdown cell it rendered
the markdown one was a code cell and
then the last one had a code cell that
called this display call which rendered
a graph for us and the same thing for
anything I print out while I'm executing
he's gonna show up as outputs in between
the cells saying this is what I said
happened during this cell okay so we've
talked a little bit about whether the
valid we use cases are but the wins
really come around the shareability the
ease of reading and the documentation
with code it also has a pretty nice
outcome that if you ran this thing the
exactly what you did is well documented
and associated so you don't have to
search through five systems to find the
logs and hope they're the right logs for
the right action that you took any other
the nice thing is it's multilingual so
while I'm gonna be showing Python code
mostly here you can run a couple of any
repple that supports the protocol that's
what the Jupiter ecosystem kind of helps
to find is that protocol so you can you
can match the different languages and
systems so how does this work a bit you
know what we just showed is really a
Jupiter UI and chicken I was showing the
interact and then you also see the
classic UI and where you have this is a
is a little bit of a simplified view of
what's actually happening of the hood
but basically you have the UI but the
user interacting with it you've loaded
some notebook file it's on some disk or
an s3 or zero
and then you have some Jupiter server
that's sitting there hosting this
website for you and replaying the
requested actions you have down to a
jupiter colonel
a colonel is a name in the notebook
space for the rapper rapper it's the
command that launches the repple and
holds the state for you oops and the one
thing to kind of note here with the the
way this communication works is the
jupiter serving the joopa Colonel kind
of fulfilled this protocol of
communication of what what messages need
to go back and forth and then the client
is sort of listening to those messages
they'll system and like execute this
code they'll send out over over a
channel and then they get back kind of
asynchronously all the outcomes until it
says I'm done executing what you
requested and all that kind of gets
hidden from you so as a user you just
need to know hey I have some code I'm
executing it there's some state being
held as that code executes so where this
really comes in as a traditional tool is
back when notebooks kind of started
becoming popularize probably in the
earlier 2000s it was really a tool for
data scientists where they could explore
and analyze data from a system or from
an external point of contact without
having to refresh that data over and
over and over again which was the
expensive part of their like iteration
cycle so you could fetch the data once
hold onto it and then try different
models try different explorations try
different queries until you were
satisfied with the result so the good
thing with notebooks is they're really
good for quick iteration capture
expensive queries they're very good at
recording your outputs and they're
pretty easy to modify you can take an
existing one touch it slightly it's kind
of a more sophisticated version of just
some Python script or some JavaScript
you have sitting around that you maybe
it's difficult someone to capture what
it did and how it works
it's a little bit improvement on that
but there's some drawbacks and these
drawbacks kind of kept it to a more
isolated community and didn't see a lot
of production use it was usually an
exploration tool and then you stop there
and rewrote everything you did in a
notebook in some system that your
company actually supported and the the
bad is the fact that like as you're
editing your notebook file without some
of the extended tools that are becoming
popularized now you lack history of what
your edits were so you don't have
version control baked in because at the
time some a version control wasn't that
popular in all groups it's a little
difficult to tell
at least traditionally the document is
mutable so if you shared it with someone
and you're both editing the same time
bad things happen some of those have
forgotten better or will become much
better in the future
and it's a little hard to parameterize
you have to make the notebook and kind
of have human readable documentation at
the top of like when you want to use
this change this value to whatever you
need right so it's not very system
friendly it's more human friendly so one
place we came in that Netflix was we had
a lot of users using notebooks and there
was a lot of friction around those users
wanting to be able to just just run this
notebook you can run my Python script I
can't you run my notebook it's already
setup to do what I want so this is where
a lot of investment came into this
library called paper mill so things that
we wanted to focus on helping improve
our users and the kind of philosophy
here was rather than forcing our users
to go away from a technology that they
liked we wanted to move our tooling
closer to support the technology they
were already using so things we want to
preserve where the results link to code
that's really nice matter of fact that's
probably the best feature of these this
system it's been the most useful for
everyone all around it's good
visualization so you can set up
notebooks it very clear about why
decisions were made especially when have
very complex data decisions you can
graph and plot the things that that
drive the engine that your X units and
it's really easy to share especially if
you make read-only interfaces which is
another technology we invested in around
notebooks but things we want to prove
what's the versioning like the fact that
you have a mutable object makes it
really hard to reason about how it's
gonna behave and how it did behave and
the fact that you couldn't really
template has a weird humid tempting
so paper mill is a sort of a pun on the
idea of turning out notebooks and such
as exactly what it does is an interact
we would it does is it actually isolates
the input in the output so paper mail
takes some input source it could be EFS
it can be mounted in s3 it can be
anywhere in the ecosystem or in the
local file system you point to one of
those schemes and pull that data in and
then you execute papermill on it and
it'll actually run through as a client
without a UI it'll run through executing
all the cells in order and then it'll
out come to an outcome location that you
specify so what this does is you can
actually specify hey
I want this to go to run 54 next time we
run 55 and so on and so forth
this means you can kind of keep a record
of everything you've ran especially for
any organization scheme around how you
store your kind of batch executions all
right so we're gonna talk a little bit
about how this looks like in code
because it's a very simple library to
interface with it isn't actually that
much code in the library if you read it
it's like less than a thousand lines but
effectively you in Python if you were to
execute this from Python since it's a
Python library it also has a CL I will
show in a minute you can just basically
call this papermill execute notebook
give an input path give an output path
to do exactly what I just described if
you ran this a bunch of times and you
parameterize your output you can see
here we use the date of the run maybe
you run date once a day you can actually
point that to an output path and then
you can read all the runs that ran there
we just use this a lot where we'll have
a job execution so the user is scheduled
and then we will map those into a unique
pass you can actually see all the
executions that ever ran for this job
definition it means you can also recall
and restore one of those like maybe last
Tuesday's run was the right thing to do
and today isn't and you need to quickly
figure out what you did last Tuesday you
can just go load what ran and rerun it
or play with it has another really nice
feature that that's introduced this is
the ability to templatized your notebook
so you have the ability here to actually
add parameters that get passed and
injected into the notebook so here let's
say we have some notebook that wants to
count the number of viewers on devices
in certain regions now if you think
that's a pretty useful little
integration maybe just do a quick query
and make a graph or do a query and ask
another system to join that data here
what we're going to be doing is we want
to basically say hey normally we run
this as default to see how many PCs are
in the u.s. that are watching the stream
maybe that's something you're interested
by default and then what you in the
notebook you'll have a cell in there
that you mark with the region and
devices and the other defaults you want
and you'll tag that cell this tag called
a parameter and then whenever a paper
mill runs it'll look for that tag and
inject code after it or if it doesn't
find this it'll just put it at the top
of your notebook so the way the template
sizing works the papermill is really
really simple
it just takes the J's
on of the inputs you're giving it and
converts that in the code in a self so
you'll get a new cell in your notebook
that has all your parameterization
applied and where this is really nice is
you can kind of choose what you override
and it's really straightforward like I
say region equals foo you're gonna get
region equals foo inside your notebook
into whatever language that notebook is
in alright so paper uh also has usages
CLI we actually use it more as a CLI
than a paper than a Python library in
particular the the CLI version here is
just like paper mill input path output
path and then you give it a bunch of
parameters in different forms with a few
options that collect them and this can
be passed in is JSON yamo individual key
value pairs and so on so forth you don't
do the same thing so if we go back to
this kind of view of how notebooks
execute and how they look when you have
a jupiter server and a user interacting
house papermill interact in this picture
well namely papermill Sora replaces the
user and the UI aspect it acts as
another client that talks over the same
protocol in the same pattern that the
the webserver would in this case all
it's doing is instead of you know
iterating on this live document it reads
in the document Dever touches the
original source sends that over the
kernel
propagates to that kernel to actually
execute gets back all the replies
collects them just like a normal you I
would and then when it's all every time
a cell finishes execution it's gonna
save to the output and what this the
only really difference here is that much
like a user would go in and edit a cell
and add in like I want region equals us
or I want region equals Canada here
papermill is doing that on your behalf
programmatically
by the having those inputs you can say
hey I want to run in this region and
then you know run this notebook for that
that particular template a is Asian it
also records what the templates are and
in the metadata and other things so it's
easy to programmatically ask what you
did all right so to dig in the bit more
on how it actually works if you look
into the details more than just hey it
takes things in and put them out it
actually has a plug-and-play framework
in here where you can give it
a notebook source and register what type
of sources what schemes you can support
it lets you inject the parameters
through variety of means and these get
injected as the cell into your code and
then it runs and talks to that it
actually launches a runtime manager that
launches the kernel under the hood as a
sub process so it's actually launching
that repple on your behalf whenever you
run based on the definition of how
Jupiter defines the spec so Jupiter sets
the whole framework we follow the
framework to launch up your repple and
run it and then shut it down when it's
all done and then the output can go to
the same source sinks as we have sources
so in our example like it it Netflix and
we use this a lot many times you always
set the sink to be s3 and we have like a
fix s3 path so we always dump it in s3
we're never gonna touch the file again
that means we have a good record of like
what happened without having to even
introduce version control yet there is
ways to also integrate this in with like
version control systems if you wanted to
pretty easily but for in our case for
like getting a very simple story this
was an easy way to get a win alright so
one of the advantage is like why would I
do things in a notebook instead of just
writing a script or having my custom
tool already know about
well things you can actually do is you
can you know now programmatically
iterate over a parameter let's say
you're doing a machine learning process
and you want to try different alpha
values for for a particular algorithm
well you could you know build a whole
ecosystem around running that or if you
already have something were you even
exploring how to apply alpha in a
notebook one of the advantages here is
you can just schedule that notebook and
not rewrite your code so you can fan out
on a property and use the same notebook
template and run it four times and then
you can parameterize for each one to see
how each of them did another really nice
thing about the way papermill set up is
that not all these interest new users
but it's also highly extensible so by
kind of adding in this new paradigm we
also gave it a lot of room for being
able to add new use cases that we didn't
think about yet in particular the way
parameterization works the way inputs
and outputs work and the way even it
excuse the notebook are all registered
in the in the classes of registry so
anyone who wants to extend the library
or use it in a new way it's very easy
for them and a couple lines of code over
and actually show how how you can do
that later but what this is actually we
have found there's open up is it opened
up the use case for using notebooks to a
lot more users than just traditionally
been used in particular you know now
it's not just stay a scientist iterating
exploring working a lot more analysts
and even a few data engineers who use
this for things where they want to see
what they're doing is they're working
and then they don't want to like risk
rewriting that and messing it up and
they want to have familiarity if they
want to go back and edit they remember
how this worked and what it looked like
and so we've been having a lot of really
good success around using paper mill to
help achieve this kind of usage and
reduce the friction for some of our
users I think the largest growing group
has probably been analysts where they
oftentimes have to write some sequel
they have to like kind of get some
outcome a report and when they have to
jump between five systems it makes their
job harder you know we talked about the
plug-and-play if today if you just
download paper mill as is it supports a
few different cloud targets out of the
box in particular s3 the various is your
de lake and I'm blobstore and the Google
Cloud started right away
obviously you need some credentials we
won't plug you into our system and say
write to our yeah and so we've we've
talked a little about the plug-and-play
architecture so I'm gonna take a little
bit more into what that actually looks
like so since the entire libraries
component based you can overwrite any
component now by having to monkey patch
anything not by having the go you know
over write code if you really had to and
there are some few users that do you do
that for specialized use cases you can
but in general most of the time you can
actually get away by just registering a
new execution that you want to do for
example let's say you have an SFTP
server you need to talk to as your
source who knows why you have that as
where your notebooks a living but it
could be or someone's trying to share
something with you externally and this
is the way they share so this is
actually be all the code you need the
right in order to add that support to
papermill you need to implement a read
function and a write function for the
file path and the file contents and then
all to register this new endpoint all
you have to do in your own setup tools
is register entry point to add the SFTP
scheme into the paper mills
iö read/write registry and after you do
this then your execution down here you
do execute notebook and say SFTP colon
slash slash my FTP path will actually
start working using your code right away
you don't actually have to monkey
patching anything this is a relatively
new feature like in the last like four
months
so our system still does the sort of
like go in and touch more directly and
there you actually do if you want to
have more of a wrappers we wrapped with
CLI and then the registry object we just
call dot register with our own path and
particularly use this for internal tools
so we have like a short link system
where you can have like we call them go
links where you can make a very short
reference like go candidate analysis you
know something like that and you can
pull that link will actually follow that
link through our system and go find the
notebook for you so you can just take
whatever URL is wherever you're looking
and always share it so the big value
here we actually really see and using
notebooks in the system is around failed
notebooks it's actually not the
successes that are good success is when
everything works you don't really care
it's when something goes wrong that you
actually care how you did something or
at least that's mostly how it plays up
so we go back to that same you know
fanning out a bunch of parameters on on
a notebook here you know if we fanned
out and one of those parameters ations
failed or some users you know it
particularly input failed traditionally
in the system you might have to go
through support and say hey my script
failed where's the air is it's the SD
out maybe you have a lot of that
collected already in the e system which
is really good but then you know each
person has to learn where those things
are one of the manages we have here is
that whenever something fails in our
system for any reason any template any
job the user can just simply go ahead
click the link see the failed job and it
actually renders in the browser very
nice this is the code you executed
here's the stack traces here's the error
message all of that and I'll show you
what that looks like I also made you can
stop propagation because it acts like a
normal process so pretend you know we
have this notebook on the right or
something where we're doing some select
statement against and spark and we want
to basically just go run this thing and
then see what happens this is the
original template and we would collect
logs and then state tapes types of
interfaces and rear honorable code so I
could rerun whatever the user ran to
as a system maintainer it's a super
useful because if the user says if you
ask the user whether they do and they
say I Iran my thing Iran the sequel and
you're like okay you forgot how to help
you here it's a lot easier being say hey
give me a link to what you ran and
basically anyone even people who don't
work on our system very quickly see oh
this is what got executed and load it
and read it you don't need to know how
the system works the only other tools
work it's pretty clear when you read
something it says it says spark and it
has some sequel in it yeah it's probably
executing sequel on spark so in
following this kind of example let's say
we ran that and we had some sort of air
the kind of execution path you go
through they're both the self service
and as a maintainer is you actually go
see what the issue was you can actually
get the stack trace any details
information already in the notebook you
can go try a fix by literally cloning
that notebook into the UI that I first
showed tweaking it until you get the
query correct or fix the configuration
issue and then you can just push that
update back to the original notebook so
if you've many of our times our
notebooks are in source control or in a
linear version control in s3 and in
there like we can very quickly go play
in another corner off a fork of this
notebook play with different
interactions figure out the answer is
and then point back to the user oh this
is what you need to change in your
notebook in order to fix it we can do
that all without like interfacing or
interacting with a user's actual
pipeline all right they don't want to
have to go and figure out there get repo
works and how they build their assets
and deploy everything is isolating
grouped together here and so that's been
really helpful for us in terms of
supporting our users and letting our
users be more self-service so the
papermill changes to the notebook
experience really is around a couple
couple artifacts that improve and make
this actually usable in production one
of the things is a notebook isolation so
we've made immutable inputs and mutable
outputs where you can isolate and not
touch you know what you ran before a
second time at also adding the
parameterization of notebook runs is
really useful for being able make these
programmatic rather than like human
driven systems and then the configurable
sourcing and sinking means that we can
have more wider broader impact so
there's a lot of different cloud systems
that now have either contributed to make
their integration better or are using
heavily the integration with paper mill
in order to talk to their system and it
the user doesn't have to relearn the
system like I'm just
here's my schema and everything works
pretty well so one thing I did want to
dig into a little bit is that one of the
places where you see notebooks get
abused much like any code getting abused
if you see one you know Python function
it has a thousand lines in it it's
probably a bad function
there's simpler cat lines around
notebooks in particular because
notebooks are hard to unit test there
are some tools out there that try to
achieve this but in general it's hard to
bundle unit tests with your dopes what
can have it be very clear how those go
together
so typically we tried not to use
notebooks as libraries they're good when
you're exploring but still to go through
the work of production izing your code
so where they shine is as an integration
tool they're really good about how to
show how you're going to talk to three
different systems come to some result
and make an app take an action that's a
really good integration where
traditionally having a library is kind
of awkward because it's talking between
many systems or may have people just
write a script and they never test it at
all notebooks do give you a little bit
better reliability here around when
things are running what they're doing
now what that means is you want to avoid
things that are highly complex you don't
want to have you know many 10 20 page
long note books and you want to make it
fairly linear so it's easy for you to
understand how it's going to run the
next time and what that means is that we
keep a low branching factor where we can
we keep it short and simple is better we
try to always keep the one primary
outcome like this thing does a task and
then we link those tasks together rather
than having one notebook which say runs
50 different jobs and then I'll updates
50 different databases so that would be
a bad use you should use one template
and use it 50 times and then the one
thing is try to leave your library
functions in libraries so oftentimes
you'll develop and you're slowly your
notebook get bigger because you'll
discover hey I need this and here's a
little helper function and utility here
and pretty soon if you get a lot of that
your notebook looks pretty dense and
much like if you're writing a script and
exploring high writing code you want to
productionize that and put the pieces
that need unit testing in a place where
you can do that so oftentimes we get big
notebooks we start noticing there being
larger we start seeing errors so show
that notebook that we didn't catch an
integration testing we will actually
move we'll move those into into
libraries that are
nearby or in some place that makes sense
like maybe the tooling they're calling
needs to have more support for different
flexible options so the the reason why
you want to do this and why using
notebooks for integration is really good
is actually using tests with paper mills
is very easy so you can when we do this
extensively at Netflix all of our
notebook templates that we provide our
users have integration tests the
integration tests look a lot like a
paper mill call the user would make so
we're basically to run it just like a
user would but we give it debug or dummy
inputs like well oftentimes point to
tables that are canary tables that we
don't care about or will point to assist
them on the test version of the cluster
instead of the product and so that also
means where the parameterization is kind
of nice and we have templates monthly
users usually open up parameters that
allow us to point to testing or debug
capabilities and then we just run our
whole suite against the test version or
wherever we need to not touch prod data
directly but it means that our our
execution calls gonna be very similar
how the users going to use it and we
know the notebook is going to run and
the end very smoothly if we have the low
branching factor and follow some of our
other practices it gives us pretty high
to very high confidence that when the
user goes to use this template it's
gonna work for them so here we have that
same sort of execution that we had
earlier where we're trying to do
something on a region but this time
we're gonna send in a region called Luna
which has a lot of users nobody it's too
early
all right so we're gonna figure out how
many people on the moon are watching
things on the particular day and we're
going to set debug the true and what you
would see in the notebook and me
actually ran out you see this parameter
cell coming in with region luna run date
of April 2nd and then debug equals true
we use this a lot just some themes and
we want to say hey debug is true so we
do dry run you can all say dry run this
too is pretty common or maybe you want
to go all the way up to a certain point
we maybe don't want to write data most
of our tests don't do this but if you do
where the the system we're talking you
doesn't have a test version or is a
little sensitive then we'll do that so
we don't actually touch generally you
want to actually touch a system so
having a test version or a dev cluster
that you can point to for your test is
good at the end of the day you know we
would run something like this maybe one
of ourselves is just a spark sequel cell
and we will run insert into the output
table collect up some click events for
the particular day and region match
really simple thing maybe we graph it
afterwards you can let the integration
test run you can
to view the results to the human eye go
see like kind of what did it do so I've
talked about paper mill and kind of how
we use it and how it's how it adds the
notebook interface and how it kind of
transforms the scripting concept of
integration but there's lots of other
goodies in the Jupiter ecosystem
especially in the past year or two that
have been added to add a lot of
flexibility and the option to go in
different directions with using
notebooks we use a host of libraries and
these are some ones we use at Netflix or
have developed on there's ones like env
convert which papermill uses in order to
do the execution commuters are read-only
notebook interface and B formats like
the the schema that actually notebooks
follow and so on and so forth so a whole
bunch of these libraries if you look at
the Jupiter github and the interact get
hub you'll see a ton of products on
there there it all have very neat and
useful capabilities so I'll talk about a
couple more that are newer that we use
or starting to use or are developing so
scrapbook is one someone said the pun
game is strong this one goes even
further this one was a fun idea that
came out of talking about well we have
notebooks as a function where you have
inputs you can template as the input in
the outputs a notebook but that output
is still something that's human readable
not program readable so scrapbook tries
to let you solve that problem by
actually registering data outcomes or
visualization outcomes in your notebook
and what this lets you do is inside your
notebook you can import scrapbook and
then you can scrapbook glue because
you're gonna glue some junk and we don't
know what it is
so you putting some nice pretty picture
in your notebook or are you putting some
data model result and in the really
basic case here you would do something
saves in a notebook and when it runs and
later you could go read that notebook
back out of your source and then ask hey
what data results were in this notebook
and collect them by name and then even
build data frames out of collections of
notebooks this is something that was
actually a functionality in early paper
mill they've been in a limited form so
scrapbook is expanding that to be more
broad and so that you can grab data from
more sources and in there this is really
handy and the original use case was
around map producing executions on on
like let's say a data science or machine
learning point of view which is why it
was an early paper mill where you want
to do an alpha parameter and find out
what your error value is where
maybe you want your confusion matrix out
put on a notebook and you want to run
this for 500 different experiments and
you want to collect with all the
confusion matrices are to choose which
you know parameterization work best this
makes it really easy to just live in the
same yuccas and don't have to save and
output someplace else and then come back
you just save your output confusion
matrix right in the notebook and then
you just recall it later it's kind of a
useful little handy tool it's a growing
thing and would love more people to give
input on interfaces here we have a few
people starting to really use it another
thing we've used very extensively
because traditionally when we first
landed in notebooks
everything was mutable which was a scary
thing when you want to share something
because what if that person changes
something and they didn't intend to or
you didn't want them to so a commuter is
a read-only interface for notebooks they
look something like this where this is
one of our templates for executing
presto you can see it's really long and
for high branch vector right it's nice
and clean so we do like trying to keep
these where the tools are already built
to just use the tool that exists and
mostly about adding logs and helpful
information so this would be something
if you read the template that we provide
users for presto and they say hey when I
register press the job what's it
actually do we can just point them to
this they can read it and they can't
edit it
same with outcomes all the results of
their jobs we always give them a
Commuter link which is a read-only
loader of s3 or local file system mount
whatever you got mounted and it doesn't
need the whole kernel and all thank you
so some ecosystem because at the end of
the day a notebook is actually just a
JSON file that's saved someplace so you
if you have something it knows what the
protocol is it can read the schema you
can render that notebook anywhere
including in editors and in read-only
interfaces like this this one's really
handy so if you are adopting notebooks I
highly suggest you look into using
commuter and just really quickly to talk
about like what how we're using
notebooks and I've talked kind of
vaguely about scheduling notebooks and
things like that we actually are very
bought into using notebooks to the point
where you might think we're a little
crazy in particular when I started at
Netflix about a year and a half ago the
this is the very start of kind of the
heavy investment in notebook
infrastructure in the data platform and
my big project that's basically coming
to conclusion now is getting several
several different scheduled systems all
to convert their data into a system it's
notebook based and it wasn't just the
chain
notebooks is actually to upgrade our
scheduler and in the process we saw
these users using notebooks and we
wanted to come closer to our users and
try the dog food what they use and fix
the problems we find rather than
complain to the technology that they
like is bad so here we've actually
changed over somewhere around 10,000
jobs which run like 150,000 queries a
day they all run through notebooks so
we're running like millions of notebooks
now and in a templatized form and we've
seen very good results of our abilities
support needs fewer people and it's much
clearer to our users what's happening
and it's much easier for our users to
contribute new templates before they had
to know us archaic system and go like
write some code and write some code
someplace else and then like click a
button someplace and then ask Joe that
turned something on you know so that
nowadays it's very easy they can say hey
here's a notebook I ran and this is how
I want to work on it we work with them
to productionize a little bit and then
we add an integration test and boom
anyone else can use it
so I can talk more about that maybe the
office hours people are interested how
that works but like we've had good
success in using this for a particular
use case and it's grown so that now data
engineers and analysts have a more
natural integration with the tools they
were starting to use are already using
heavily awesome so that's all I had
[Applause]
yes the question was around dependencies
and actually in a data sense there's two
types of dependencies like library
dependencies you need and then there's
data dependencies you need um today we
plan those more at the scheduler system
above so when you're scheduling
something you're going to specify hey I
need this data to be fresh for this time
period or for this partition or
something like that and so you actually
specify and when you're scheduling the
notebook based on how you're gonna
parametrize that you is the author of
the of the job no best for library
dependencies that's a little bit of a
harder story which is actually starting
to evolve with notebooks in particular
but it's not just isolated the notebooks
traditionally we lean on the system's
are already in place for dependency
management which is around we have a
container that has most the libraries we
use and then we give an easy way for
users to add in new packages they need
on the fly and if they commonly use it
we ask them to get them into the image
that's shared for that user group that
works pretty well to a point there will
be some scale point where that stops
working especially as we get people who
write less than good libraries that
conflict with each other but we've been
able to keep like maybe a half-time FTE
able to keep that running pretty
smoothly for users and that's at the
scale of you know Big Day APOD for my
Netflix so you can go pretty far yeah I
would love to talk about that more
afterwards there's some good changes
coming on inside notebooks being able to
specify your dependencies in a better
way there are ways to do it
hack Elite today yeah I think sure we
can go here and then there
how do people collaborate while working
on notebooks like if you want to try out
something then you want to let it give
it to somebody else where they can maybe
add a few things or like add a few
comments on your work and then give you
a new version where you can work on it
is that kind of a workflow that you have
or support there is a some support for
that in particular when we show that
commuter interface the the question by
the way if those I couldn't hear was how
do you do collaboration is that
something you actually do with notebooks
where you share and need someone to give
you feedback we actually have on our
read-only interface we have a commenting
system so you can there's a plug-in and
able to register where you can comment
kind of Google Doc style and and then
resolve and answer questions there and
then that's associated with your
notebook
object the the source of truth so it
gives the opportunity for someone to
comment on a version of a notebook and
then we also use another tool called
bookstore to help version our notebooks
so the yeah and someone's dying from the
puns the so that yeah there are tools
there out of the box if you started from
scratch and just shared your notebook
link yeah sharing and commenting there's
not good because if two people edit the
live server at the same time bad things
happen the only system that really does
that well is okolab used to have it and
they don't anymore when they change the
api's on the hood they lost that ability
and partially because it wasn't a very
common story because it's kind of weird
at someone's code while they're editing
there's a one other there's a couple of
tools that do allow you to use it so I
would look around the ecosystem out of
the box you won't have it and a question
back there
um so in our pipelines and ETLs and even
parts of the pipeline takes more CPU
more memory and parts require GPU have
you found a way to do this dynamically
so that your notebook could take three
hours to execute but you're one part of
your pipeline requires a more RAM but
the other doesn't if you don't
containerize it if you just run it on
one machine it will just work because
it's just gonna less use less RAM and
CPU but if you start container izing it
and running on in kubernetes it's
allocating a hundred gigs of memory for
the whole entire thing have you found a
solution to that there's a couple things
we do one is maybe break your problem up
so you can have one template for the
expensive part a separate that's pretty
common
another is sometimes if the other parts
where you're holding all that memory are
short just go ahead and waste the
resources because it's more effort to
have a human try and fix the problem
more money to have a human fix the
problem sometimes then just let it be
but when there are a few tools and this
actually is more at the orchestration
side where there's some experimentation
around because we do all container based
execution so that's part of the
isolation that we have there are
container orchestration system which is
noble source tool called titus is
exploring with ideas around giving the
minimum resources you need so you can
get up to something and if you're not
using all the resources to be able to
let nearby containers take more of the
resources on the Box it's still kind of
experimental thing but generally I would
say the better solution is to break up
your problem so that the expensive thing
uses its resources for most of the
containers lifecycle
you